good afternoon everyone it's good to see
you um we're gonna get going in a
quote-unquote
new topic um you're probably used to
this by now right what have we covered
in extension two so far we've looked at
your very first topic was
complex numbers and even though in a
real way it's like oh this is new
squares and negative numbers we've kind
of been anticipating it
for years like the first time you met a
quadratic equation
and you you know you we carefully gave
you equations where
everything turned out nicely right and
then maybe one time you
press some buttons by accident you're
like oh math error when i was trying to
put in my you know quadratic equation we
said don't worry
don't worry about that maybe if you're
worthy we will explain this to you one
day
and then complex numbers arrive right so
that was a continuation
right um 3d vectors was also
a continuation of of
3d vectors with continuation of vectors
two d vectors right which we did in
extension one probably the only truly
quote unquote um new thing we've done in
extension two
has been the nature of proof but even
half of the nature of proof was
um harder mathematical induction which
again continuation of mathematical
induction
we're going to drill down deeper into
another
area of the calculus courses you've been
doing advanced extension one
and that's integration which i know
everyone's been in the thick of right in
terms of what you've been doing in
extension one
so we're going to try and i'm going to
try and piece together everything for
you so if you haven't already what i'd
like you to draw
and you'll need the full width of your
page to do this because it's going to
get busier than this
in a second you'll need three concentric
circles
that gets smaller as you go in to the
center of the page as concentric circles
tend to do
so what do we know within the advanced
course when it comes to integration
um this is going to be a vast
oversimplification but i just want to
give you
some broad brush strokes so we can
connect the relevant
concepts okay um integration or integral
calculus
is kind of one half of calculus what's
the other half
differentiation right and that's kind of
oh turn it on
trained trained professional we've done
that before
differentiation is where we began right
everything you learned about how to take
a function
and get its gradient out of it that was
what we covered as we introduced this
idea in fact
some of your textbooks and some times
perhaps some of your lessons we would
have talked about
uh integration before we introduced that
idea we would talk about
anti-differentiation right not exactly
the same
but pretty closely related and it was
all about this idea of change right
calculus is all that change
um what does the derivative tell you in
terms of change
it tells you gradient right but more
than gradient like gradient back in
corner geometry days
gradient was you've got one spot where
you started and one spot where you ended
and gradient was the is the rate of
change it's the rise over run
over this interval right what was
special what was more powerful
about differentiation instantaneous
gradient very nice it's not an average
over like this amount of time or this
amount of space it was like at this
particular point
right so differentiation how would we
say it
it's an instantaneous rate of change
an instantaneous rate of change
that's so important it's actually worth
writing down and i didn't get my wiper
markers out
that instantaneous rate of change
how does it contrast
to uh integration instead of an
instantaneous rate of change
[Music]
i can fit it here
instead of an instantaneous rate of
change what we've got
in integration is well it's not
instantaneous
generally what are we interested when in
when we talk about integration
like we've got lower and upper bounds so
what's the opposite of instantaneous in
this context
hmm well the whole idea of instantaneous
is to get away from an interval
and to get to like one single instant in
time i guess the opposite of this in the
context of integration would be
there's an accumulation right it's like
over time we accumulate
well not a rate of change but a
accumulated total of changes which often
looks like an
area does that make sense so we sort of
compare this
instantaneous rate of change to an
accumulation
of total change i remember the first
time i was introduced the idea that
area is the opposite of gradient and
geometrically
that's weird why should the opposite of
gradient be area
but when i saw this i was like oh i get
it now right
single point of time interval of time
right
rate compared to what happens when you
add up over this whole interval
so this is the place where we begin
right and the lion's share of everything
you know about
integration you know from
differentiating first
and then we kind of spent a while taking
all those rules of differentiation that
you know
and then turning them into integration
rules right so for example
if the uh derivative
of a polynomial term is going to be
equal to say it with me
and x to the n
minus one right we bring the coefficient
we multiply by the coefficient and then
we
sorry multiply by the index and then
reduce the index by one
how do you turn this differentiation
rule into an integration rule
we're going to do these same two things
but reversed right and the order also
matters
we did this second before so now we'll
do it first we will
increase the index right and then we
will instead of multiplying we'll
divide by the index right and um much
confusing
confusion ensued when we were like which
one are we doing we get them mixed up
quite easily right but you got better at
it we've had a lot of practice right
we did it with particular kinds of
functions like polynomials what else do
you know how to differentiate and
therefore integrate
what other kinds of families or
functions do you have you're
trigonometric what else
okay we've got exponentials i'm going to
put like an asterisk on logarithms
because
we can differentiate logs and end up
with a gradient function
but we can't integrate logs can we at
least not in a straightforward way
we can integrate a thing that becomes a
log something that looks like
this right what would you call this this
has a special name
so i'm gonna well i'm gonna come to i'm
gonna come to that in a second but like
this object here
we've got some function divided by some
other function
it's a ratio between two functions right
so we would call this a
rational function doesn't really matter
so much what you call it but knowing
what
this is about is important so we can
integrate something like this it ends up
being a log so this is the whole idea
like we
ended up taking a lot of the
differentiation rules and then turning
them backwards
right we spent a lot of time doing that
and then kind of the large
major idea and it's a very very major
idea was we said
after doing this anti-differentiation
idea constant integration all that kind
of thing primitive functions right
we noticed that it was well trying to
get this accumulated id
right it's kind of different to when
you've got a definite integral when you
put numbers in you substitute right
and someone's already mentioned it a
definite integral gives us something
quite different to a gradient function
it gives us
an area but more than an area what kind
of
area does it give us does anyone know
so it's often called an area under a
curve right but
i defy all of you to think about the
fact that it's different to the area
that you've
learned for years and years yeah maybe
my function was a clue right if i gave
you something like this right
and i asked you what the area was right
a year seven student could look at those
um triangles get the dimensions and off
you go
right but that's not what we would do if
we did the integral from
say negative one to one of this function
right we all know that we would not get
what that u7 student would get what we
get in this case we get zero
because it's not just area it's signed
area we're allowed to have
negative areas depending on their
position which is slightly weird but
it's a different idea so this is where
we went right
and we spent a long time on it but
that's not where we ended now
for me one of the things that is kind of
sort of where it begins right you know
how you told me you could do polynomials
you could do trig
etc this is kind of how a lot of
advanced integration felt to me when i
was learning
maybe it feels like to you it's
basically like what does this thing look
like
is it you know going to be a trig
function it's going to turn into a trig
function
it's going to be a polynomial it's going
to turn to another polynomial and it's
just a fairly
straightforward this is the thing fit it
into there does that make sense
but as we've gone further we want to get
away from this metaphor this is the way
integration can feel in advance
but we wanted to give you more knowledge
to expand your idea of what integration
can do
so i told you draw concentric circles
right where the second
layer out what have we learned and we've
done it fairly recently so maybe you can
help me
what have we learned under extension one
integration there's really three key
ideas i'd say
okay so there's this idea of
substitution now i've drawn an arrow
here to connect this right
because introducing a substitution to
help you
integrate something right when you see
something such as
when you see something like this right
introducing a substitution like in this
case what do you think would be helpful
u might be equal to x cubed minus one
i've deliberately written this question
so it sort of stands out in front of you
right
introducing a substitution here is
really just the reversal of a rule that
you saw before and this goes to
calvin did you mention it no who
mentioned it um
yeah a few of you this is reversing the
chain rule like this is what you would
get
if you differentiated something you know
something like x cubed minus 1 to the
power of eight i don't know exactly
where the coefficient would be
right a lot of the rings today hey
that's fine
that's okay yes sir obviously you're
looking at a few different ideas here
um we're just reversing the channel
that's all substitution
is right does this make sense so you can
see there's this connection between what
you learned in advance
once you learnt in extension one give me
something else this is not the only
thing you've learnt in extension one
integration
okay fantastic you've got all these
trigonometric
identities that is extension one
students you have access to
that in advance we didn't learn right so
those help you integrate a whole bunch
of things that you couldn't have
otherwise like
sine squared and cos squared come to
mind right
then lastly right as a major idea anyway
i'm skipping over a lot of stuff we've
also learned about other kinds of
functions within extension 1
and so we learn how to differentiate and
integrate those most specifically
we think about inverse functions the
most famous ones you know
are the inverse trig functions which
we're going to look at shortly
but these come out of the fact that well
in extension one we've got inverse
functions
let's learn how to differentiate
integrate them make sense
okay now this has made things harder but
i'm going to say
this is kind of like you know that box
toy that i showed you before
um the kids sort things into i'm just
going to say this is kind of like
a bigger box with more holes and more
different things to fit into it right
what we're going to do in extension 2 is
blow the lid
off of the box okay um like i said no
simplification but this is gonna be the
path that we're gonna chart through very
roughly
four ideas i think number one uh you've
already passed had this mentioned to you
by some of your teachers
we're going to keep on this idea of
integration by substitution but
unlike in extension 1 exams where we
will always always always
tell you what the substitution is we'll
say let u equal whatever
we won't specify in extension 2.
sometimes we will if we're feeling
charitable but other times it's like you
know what just work it out
sometimes it's not that hard to work it
out other times
more challenging we'll get to those
shortly okay so that's a big difference
if you think back to this idea of
reversing the rules
we get to learn this it sounds very
intimidating and scary right this new
technique called integration by parts
um it's just a fancy way of reversing a
different rule that you learnt
all the way back in advance does anyone
know which one it is
it's kind of it's kind of reversing the
product rule it's not about integrating
a
product per se it's not quite as
straightforward as that but it's using
the product rule
in reverse
four ideas two down two to go uh we're
going to look at these ideas called
recurrence relationships or some
textures call them
reduction formulas sometimes if you want
to think back to say
mathematical induction right sometimes
when you did a mathematical induction
proof
you were doing the you assumed for n
equals k and then you did okay let's
prove true for
n equals k plus one and then you started
doing this big part of the work and then
you realize oh
i need to prove something else in order
to make this work right it's like a
secondary proof
when it comes to integration we have
this equivalent problem where sometimes
you integrate something
but integrating creates another integral
that you have to solve
right so it's integrals within integrals
it's sort of like a
uh your dog i heard you like integrating
so i put a function in your function so
you can integrate while you integrate
that kind of idea right that took me
more times to practice then i'll admit
now
then then lastly uh we're going to have
a look at a lot more algebraic
manipulation that's going to make your
eyes water a little bit but once you get
used to it you'll be fine
these things called partial fractions
which
it's a bit tricky as teachers who've
taught the course a bunch of times mrs
lees and i are used to connecting this
to something back in the old course that
you used to do so
we'll have to be careful with this one
but we're going to be dealing with
polynomials that are identical to each
other
and then sort of attaching fractions to
them and using that to help us
integrate things that look impossible to
integrate otherwise you're like i want
it to look like this
i want it to look like this and it
doesn't what else can we do with that
answer
we can do a process called decomposition
break it into fractions we can deal with
okay so this is the roadmap this is
where we're going to go
and as i said we're trying to change the
metaphor right so here's what i want to
leave you with before we actually do
some of this right
i don't know if any of you know what
this is
or have seen enough of this by now what
is it like 10 years or something in
australia
um someone tell me what this is this is
master chef but specifically within
masterchef this is called a it's called
a mystery box right and the idea
is everyone walks in all the contestants
and it's like what's
under the box and there's some
ingredients in there right
now the reason why i think this is a
better metaphor or more suitable
metaphor to what we're going to do in
extension two
integration is number one when you open
up and you see what ingredients are
there
it's not just a matter of oh this is the
ingredient this is the thing you do with
it the whole point is to actually be
creative and there are
for every single one of these questions
you're going to meet there will almost
always be multiple paths
through the integration some are easier
than others and we will do our best to
try and help you identify which is the
easiest one but there will just be lots
of different ones right as opposed to
it's pretty much just one way to
integrate this right
we're trying to get away from that we're
trying to give you more interesting
problems
uh secondly secondly if you were
if you were this contestant in
masterchef right you lift the lid and
then
lo and behold a bunch of ingredients
right
do you start do you like immediately go
and like find a particular pan to use
or get a particular knife out right or
do you start to turn on the oven
you can't do any of these things
immediately can you because what do you
have to do first
say one more time kevin thank you i just
love it he gets it in one right
you have to think you have to think
it's not just a matter of here's the
thing and i'm just going to like blindly
put it into particular spots
until eventually i can ram it in right
you have to
think and consider really carefully
here's one of the tricky things about
this right
each of these methods you're going to
use
they're often much longer than the
integration you're used to right how
many lines will this take maximum like
three max three right unless you really
want to stretch it out but it's not much
more you could do it in less if you knew
what you're doing right
with these we're going to see like page
long integration questions
right and what that will often mean is
you need to think
before you even begin you've got to
craft a path
through this so it's a bit more like the
nature of proof questions that you do or
even the 3d vectors questions like
stop don't just start writing stuff use
this first
right that automaticity you've gotten
used to an advanced extension one
um this ain't going to cut it in
extension 2. make sense